Good morning.
Welcome to authors at Google,
Cambridge and welcome to pride week.
It's my enormous pleasure to kickoff pride week here in Cambridge by introducing
um,
for exceptionally talented writers.
They happen to be trans women.
Uh,
they are part of the growing group of top side press writers who are giving
voice to people whose voices have one soon been denied and the publishing world
and who are changing lives.
Even as we stand here today,
we have four writers who are part of the top side press,
northeastern tour,
uh,
two writers.
We'll be back in Cambridge a week from tomorrow,
the 17th at the location whose name I forget,
but who read Dirk and I can probably remind us of this morning.
We will come image in Benny Red Durkin,
Casey Platt and Jean Thorton imaging.
Beeni writes a monthly column in maximum rock and roll magazine as well as the z
means.
The fact that it's funny doesn't make it a joke and stereotype threat.
She was contributor to the top side press,
the collection short fiction from the transgender Van Guard,
which I highly recommend.
She was recently named a recipient of the 2014 Betty Berzon emerging writer
award.
Also her novel in Nevada,
which is available in the back of the room after the talk has been the reason
subject of,
not one,
not two,
but three video games produced at one of our more priesthood move,
most prestigious engineering universities,
Georgia Tech University alongside another classic of the genre.
James Baldwins Giovanni's room.
Um,
so there you have it.
If you ever,
never thought you would see a video game based on Giovanni's room.
Uh,
I never did.
We're both wrong.
Red Dworkin,
um,
is for obscure reasons,
sadly by default,
the prettiest and funniest standup comedian in New York City.
Now she,
um,
she's also a very talented writer and a dog.
Had activist.
She is the managing editor of pretty queer.com.
Just written nine scenes and it was featured in the final issue of Punk Planet
magazine and contributed to the collection
Casey Platte,
who's just published a collection of stories,
a safe girls love dedication of which was particularly near to my heart
previously.
She wrote a column on transitioning from McSweeney's Internet tendency and
contributed to the collection.
And Jean Thornton is the author of the Black Emerald,
which is forthcoming later this year.
And the dream of Doctor Bantam,
which was a lambda award finalist for 2012 as well as the web comics bad mother
and the man who hates fun.
Please join me in welcoming miss for very talented writers.
Hi everybody.
I'm a gene Thornton,
so,
oh,
that's creepy.
I don't want to look at that.
Okay,
so I'm going to read you from the beginning of my book,
the dream of Dr Blanton,
um,
which is in the back.
And let's just go,
let's just get this started.
Okay.
It's beginning of the book you need no context is trying to be night hop.
It's cool.
Tabitha thatch argued her little sister Julie always thought about cats.
It was rare that Tabitha argued much more common that she agreed to rules or
demands her mother or the world and posted on her and then did the opposite of
what she had agreed to.
But when she did argue for job relaxed,
open inner voice,
high pitched and ragged folded in on itself in a hundred tissue paper,
layers of connotation,
implication meaning all of her yelling protest in a way that you couldn't
ignore.
You can listen to Tabitha yelling or arguing like a cat for hours.
Julie,
her own voice like a dog she thought short and course and Barky had listened to
Tabitha for hours.
You could listen and you would be struck by how raw and vibrant that voice was
but then you would realize that Tabitha was just saying she was going to go to
the mall and buy Adderall to swallow with beer and then hanger on the food court
talking about the misfits with some college kid in a raw and vibrant and cat
like waste.
She would tell you that and you would believe in her.
Linda,
Tabitha and Julie's mother had never been vulnerable to Tabitha is voice and
Juliet always hated Linda A.
Little bit for that.
They were fighting now tabs and Linda,
their voices came through the walls of Julie's bedroom like foreign talk radio
on the am dial.
Julie set up the edge of her bed recently stripped of its Alpha but pattern case
and replaced with a more grownup deep green color that reminded her of rain
forests.
She felt her long hair sticking up in crazy roller coaster loops at the back of
her head.
The air of the room was somehow just wrong,
like Lucy and voyage of the dawn treader.
She had slipped into another dimension when in which she was not able to get any
sleep before her Algebra test.
The next day when in which the red digital Clark was blinking midnight at in
some sick parody of good morning,
she went into the hallway,
cylinder white apple records,
tee shirt and boxers sat on the floor outside Linda's bedroom,
curled her legs up to her body and listened to them.
Everything has to have a reason.
That's your problem.
Tabitha was saying,
what if my reason is that I just want to spend all day lying in a field or
something and writing long letters,
sex,
boyfriends.
What if that's my reason?
I don't give a shit what your reason is.
Linda says,
Linda said,
I don't care how boring or irrelevant you think your classes are either.
You think I don't spend eight or nine hours a day doing boring and irrelevant
stuff.
I think you're spending right now doing boring and irrelevant stuff.
So Tabitha does right now count toward those eight or nine hours.
It's called survival.
Said Linda,
you do what you have to in order to survive.
It's not called fun or quit school.
So I could go out with boys and work at a fucking video arcade and smoke pot in
the house all day.
At least smoke pot in the garage.
I'm an adult,
said Tabitha.
I can possibly make decisions without subjecting them to some neurotic process
of analysis about what my possibly go wrong.
You're 17 and said Linda and the video or cage is a good job.
Said Tabitha mother.
Linda left.
Julie buried her cheeks deeper into a bear.
Bony Nice.
There are no good jobs.
Linda said there are only lucrative jobs that you hate.
Your job isn't either lucrative nor do you hate it.
I'll move out.
Said Tabitha,
that kind of left.
That's cool.
I like this place.
Okay,
I'll move out to Tabitha.
All move out and maybe Julie will come with me and you won't have is hanging
around all the time making your life miserable.
Your Stone said,
Linda,
I'm not going to argue with you while you're stoned.
You,
your stone said Tabitha,
get out of my room.
Said Linda,
go to bed and you're going back to school in the morning.
You're going to tell them you change your mind about leaving.
Ooh.
Get Out of my room.
Said Tabitha.
The TV came on immediately.
Some infomercial,
there was a snort and then a stomp and then Julie's size.
We're blinded by the lamp light.
Tabitha stormed into the hallway and slammed the door behind her.
She turned in her eyes,
fell into the ball of Juliet or feet.
She stopped before her sister.
What the fuck are you doing in the hallway?
She asked reuse.
Spying on us.
Yes.
Julie said Tabitha stared down at her.
Julie steered back up with Tabitha.
Got like this.
You could not be reasonable.
You only had to match her crazy for crazy
even in the dark hallway.
Julie thought her older sister was very beautiful.
Her hair.
Hey blonde like Julie's bleached and highlighted in pink like celery stalks and
red water.
Her skirt torn her stockings.
Striped her skirt or shirt full of rhinestones like the constellations that
Julie like to memorize from books and try to see through the fluorescent haze of
Boston street lights.
The rhinestones spelled out.
No Future Tabitha.
Put her hands on her hips and pursed her mouth.
Her lips were painted in red and outlined in black.
The epilepsy of her leather jacket rose and fell as she breathed.
C'Mon Tabitha said.
Let's get out of here.
Where are we going?
Julie asked anywhere,
but here is to Tabitha.
I don't know.
We'll get pancakes.
Come on.
Julie got up the shoulders of a t shirt nearly even with Tabitha is epaulets.
Somehow at 13 she had become as tall as her sister when she wasn't paying
attention.
Let me go get dressed.
She asked,
you'll take forever.
[inaudible] the come on.
Trust me.
Let's just go.
It's the millennium.
Julie's flip flops were stacked under the coat rack by the door.
She put them on and followed.
Tab without into the front yard,
cross the line.
Inner apple records,
tee shirt and boxers or like shivered in the spring night and every window and
every neighbor's house could have been an eyeball.
She got into the car next to her sister.
She lit a cigarette.
The Tulip of fire surrounded by the black pedals.
Ever painted nails against the light horizon were read at the edges.
She turned the key.
They didn't talk as they drove down 20 to 22 and merged under the highway during
south one of Tabitha smashing pumpkin cds was blaring quietly.
10th of tossed your filter out the window,
licked her lips and then looked over at Julie Shit.
She said,
I can't take you to get pancakes in your boxers and must be losing my mind.
She giggled again and she veered off the highway throwing Julie shoulders
against the seatbelt.
Be careful Julie hist.
They fish tailed under the overpass.
The CD played on Tabitha.
Flicked her blinkers off and on in time with it.
While Julie stared at her,
dug her nails into her seat.
They pulled into the parking lot.
If it all night.
Walmart,
Tabitha,
open the door and swung her legs out.
What are we doing here?
Julie said what?
Dress size or you said Tabitha?
I have no idea.
So Julie can we just go home?
No.
Said Tabitha happily.
Come on.
Guess you have to do in your dress size for Julie guest for not a Tabitha.
She took the keys out of the ignition,
tossed him to Julie and shut the door.
You can listen to the CD if you want.
She said just if you do leave the window rolled down a little,
otherwise gases and stuff will come in from the engine and they'll kill you.
She gave a two finger cub scouts salute and then jogged off toward the store.
Julie's sat alone in the car for a minute listening to the engine,
a creek and settle and needing to pee and then she picked up the keys and turned
on the CD player.
There was a new song,
quiet and creepy.
A man was pushing a shopping cart filled with bulky trash bags under the curb by
the dark part at the edge of the store.
The gray hood bunched up around his skull.
She looked at the window half rolled down and wondered if you could smell the
gas from the engine killing you and if the sleepiness she felt in her temples,
men that it might already be too late.
She turned off the CD,
but that only made the dread worse and she couldn't figure out how to turn it
back on.
You took forever.
She said to Tabitha when her sister hustled back into the car and handed her a
white fat white shopping bag size forest's attempts to put them on.
There was a pair of jeans in the bag.
Where am I supposed to put them on as Julie,
Jesus said,
Tabitha the backseat.
Where else do you change clothes and a car.
Julie tapped her fingers the bag and then clambered between the seats,
the leather in the back,
reeked of Pot and incense and she stretched her legs out over the piles of
forgotten school papers that filled up it.
This car,
a skeleton key chain,
long abandoned dug into her behind the windows are up and she said,
right sit Tabitha.
People only notice park cars if the windows get all fucked up.
So even though it may seem like the exact wrong thing to do,
if you're getting physical with a boy,
you'll want to leave the windows up and remember that you're stupid in stone.
So Julie,
I'm never getting physical with the boy,
with the girl.
Then it's habits for Shrek,
whatever.
It's the millennium.
Julie flushed in the dark.
You're stoned.
She repeated
it.
She closed her eyes.
She pretended that she was not sitting in a parked car with her sister and she
shrugged off her box.
Here is she carried the new genes on archer back to struggle with the last two
inches of hip and the snaps.
They're too tight.
She breathed size for my ass at Tabitha.
Come on,
squeeze him in there.
She's still managed.
It snapped.
Zipped,
tried to breathe and succeeded.
She sat up still.
Okay.
She opened the door and began to circle the car.
Walking the pants on the jeans wear boot cut screen painted neon flames rising
from the cuffs.
She winced as her bare souls pushed against the crack glass asphalt.
She was walking commando through a parking lot at night and tight Jean.
She had just gone out and bought with her sister.
Why not snap like that?
Tabitha was behind the wheel stoned and fiddling with the CD player,
giving her a thumbs up and nodding in time with Cherub rock out of the speakers.
And she looked at her sister and she loved her.
You like a mess,
Tabitha.
They're not like cutting off circulation in your legs.
They're the best pants ever.
Julie said,
you make them work set tab of Tabitha,
come on,
let's get pancakes.
And so they pulled out of the parking lot and under the highway like a jet
screaming and takeoff a jet that sounded like Billy Corgan and stank like an
ashtray at a renaissance fair.
And Julie decided that there would never be a better moment than this in her
entire life.
Thank you all very much.
MMM.
My
name is Red Durkin.
Um,
I've got about an hour's sleep in me.
so this will be fun.
That'd be great.
Um,
I'll say it.
Yeah,
I,
I was interested.
I'm a comedian,
but my writing is really not very funny.
So,
um,
I'm going to read my story from the collection,
which is titled a Roman incident.
Um,
and all you need to know about that is that it's the term for when somebody
throws up during an eating contest.
Um,
to Charlie's immediate left stood a man who had once eaten 21 pounds of grits
and 10 minutes all along the table in front of her clad in the same free tee
shirt.
She wore adventurous amateurs,
stood shoulder to shoulder with vetted professionals who made their living
rushing down enough food to kill civilians.
Charlie prayed,
oh,
Jeez.
Oh,
it went away.
All right,
I'll try to not let that happen again.
Sorry.
Um,
Charlie prayed that intense short minutes.
She'd have earned a place in the fellowship of the ladder.
I see terror filled her empty stomach.
She could afford to lose some of her nerve,
but none of her appetite.
She closed her eyes and counted down from 10 at zero with the world completely
exploded.
Lights flashed buzzers,
blared and a crowd of thousands surging like a bore tide crashed into the
security gate there.
Cacophonous excitement splashed onto the stage along with waves of their beer.
Charlie was face down in her fourth mouthful of chicken when Pavlovian reflex
gateway to human awareness and she realized what was happening.
The Hooters world wing eating championship had begun.
Her destiny was at the bar at the bottom of the pile of poultry parts in front
of her.
She couldn't afford to be reckless.
Every wing had to be clean in order to count,
so she quickly rendered each one to polish bone before moving onto the next
behind her,
a gorgeous girl and emphatically tight orange shirt.
Shorts held a scorecard above her head.
The woman bounced and smiled and cheered,
faking her enthusiasm the way Charlie imagined her mother had taught her in part
of her heart.
Charlie would always bear a hateful jealousy for women like this.
She begrudge them their big friendly breasts.
They're happily bulging hips.
All the legible parts of their bodies that spoke woman in every language.
Charlie's inscrutable frame would never carry that confident kind of currency.
And she scored the pretty girls for their oblivious luck.
When she was nine,
she had posted a note on the fridge that said Charlie is a girl and she needs
new clothes.
Um,
oh God.
Now what's this doing?
Well,
he even saved me.
Yeah,
that's weird.
I don't know anything about like technology.
Is this a tech savvy crowd?
Okay.
Should be.
Great.
Thank you.
Um,
so,
uh,
to recover a little bit,
Charlie hits pretty girls.
Um,
when she was nine,
she had posted a note on the fridge that said Charlie is a girl and she needs
new clothes.
End of discussion some years earlier to get out of an intervention.
Charlie's father had declared that the words end of discussion meant exactly
that in the Eagle Horn household it was family law.
The phrase had been employed when she was 12 and demanded to go on hormones.
And most recently at 17 when she declared her intention of becoming a
professional speed eater,
one minute down,
one bowl of wings,
Eaton,
Charlie's heart kicked like a mule,
anxiety throbbed in her temple.
Her jaw stiffen too quickly.
She knew if she didn't calm down and steady her pace,
she'd be lucky to finish it all.
But she was operating on a level based or than prudence.
It was the reptile part of her brain that was grabbing and chewing and
swallowing.
She couldn't hear the sloppy roar of the crowd or the glut grunting,
gluttony of the competition like the few other women on stage.
She was pelted with the countless ugly words for girls that flies so easily from
the mouths of angry drunk and men.
She blocked it out.
She'd had practice tears and snot gushed down her face.
She was soaked in a marinade of sweat and buffalo sauce.
Grab,
chew,
swallow each spicy wing tasted more like sy Styrofoam and her cheeks.
Bulged with untutored meet every bedraggled second took a lifetime to pass.
It was beginning to feel like home.
She'd been raised by a pair of New England hippies who'd moved to Alabama
because they liked the leaves and autumns and in autumn and acquainted dirt
roads with rustic honesty.
The Eagle Horn settled in a truck stop town outside of Montgomery called hope
hole,
which was an appropriate name for a place so utterly gutted.
Have anything worth looking forward to?
Oh my God,
it just it again.
So I chose,
I chose to read this story because my other stories are really gross and
upsetting and now I'm like,
oh,
I should have just been gross and upsetting.
All right.
The little horn settled in a truck stop town outside of Montgomery called hope
hole,
which was an appropriate name of for a place so utterly gutted.
Have anything worth looking forward to.
The Charlie is a girl campaign had been one of the most successful political
movements in its entire history as a homeschooled hippie welp growing out up on
the fringes of an outskirt town.
She was practically invisible to anyone who didn't share their meals with her.
Between her mother's home style,
lopsided haircuts,
and her father's surprisingly successful approach to homeopathic endocrinology.
Those lucky enough to lay eyes on her were neither certain of NORC curious about
what they were looking at.
Her parents claimed her as their daughter and so long as you didn't have the
audacity to dye your hair pink or the nerve to be dark skin hope holes residents
where a proudly credulous bunch Charlie suddenly realized she couldn't remember
the last time she'd taken oxygen into her lungs.
She wondered how long her animal mind had been screaming.
All the pain and confusion she'd foist it on it were immediately hers to deal
with again.
Four more minutes had passed,
four and a half more bowls,
55 wings and all the top half of her body was covered in Gore.
Her job load,
white hot with pain,
her esophagus burning with the sensation of being strangled from the inside out.
She tried to swallow,
but the blockage in her throat only shuffled in place.
She snatched a couple of water from the table and gulped it down the lump.
Lurched mercifully as it finally moved to take its rightful place in her
stomach.
She gassed a great mouth full of air and the agony all over her body began to
register on an all too conscious level.
Her fingers hurt.
She took another deep breath and close her eyes.
She forced herself to master the pain.
She refused to go back to hustling.
Arrogant rednecks at the off ramp burger joints that composed hope holes economy
at once.
At one time,
those moments had been proud and meaningful victories.
Now they felt more like the glory day nails in her inevitably mediocre coffin.
She was willing to eat her way out of that Shit Splat town,
even if it killed her.
She picked up another wing just in time to catch a blur of green glass in her
periphery.
The bottle cracked her just above the eye and everything went white in an
instant.
Charlie had been hit before.
Of course,
by her mid teens.
She traded her bean pole,
adolescent androgyny for a sexless Lee,
a morphous obesity to the idol and idiot youth of hope whole.
Charlie was a Mira of cardinal social sins.
She was fat,
opinionated and ineffably weird looking.
She had the disturbing habit of reading for pleasure and her free spirited
Yankee kin might as well have been Martians.
The girls spit in her hair and laughed at her back.
The boys called her a fagot because she confused them.
They punched her,
she punched back and slowly they all learned how to fight together.
Her soul companion was a pig nose girl named Lulu,
who brazenly forced the friendship to garner disapproval from her pig faced
family in fluttering flashes.
The world began to focus.
She'd staggered back from the table,
but was still in the competition.
Precious seconds had been lost to semi consciousness and she warded off wary
medics to keep from losing more.
The red in her,
I might well have been buffalo sauce.
Her throbbing had reminded her of home.
She wanted to sleep.
She needed to eat.
She split the difference and looked around four more minutes to go and only
eight of the original 20 km com competitors still stood on the line for the
first time.
She could see that just passed the grist grits eater and a bloated man wearing
novelty.
Sunglasses stood Sonia Thomas,
the black widow.
She was as felt Korean born woman who had managed a burger king before becoming
the second highest rank or agitator on earth.
She held a dozen world records and according to the scoreboard,
a chicken wing that would put her 26 points out of reach.
Charlie's stomach suddenly felt like a much smaller place somewhere outside of
her body.
She could see herself chewing again.
She had never planned on beating Sonia Thomas.
She'd only prayed she,
she wouldn't show up.
Some people want to kill their idols,
but Charlie didn't want a fight.
She just wanted to get out of Alabama.
A mechanical Walt settled over her body,
grab,
chew,
swallow.
She struggled to distract herself from the replete pain and doubt welling up in
her guts.
She thought back to home and the perpetual motion of her life as a podunk pariah
in the dregs of her diffidence.
She knew that she'd fed the beast,
had let the hurt go deeper than skin and had grown fatter,
weirder,
even meaner.
As a result,
she'd craved the hard touch of a town that would never claim her as their own.
Never love her,
never brag about her.
Her hope had been shining through and ever clenching Pinhole,
but in that lens she'd seen the widow competing on television.
Charlie recognized her kindred in strife,
another misfit among rubes she saw and Sonia Thomas a whisper of freedom,
a liberty to dance on the edge of womanhood and thrive.
Charlie's training had started the spring.
She turns 17 her parents met her intentions of becoming a major league either
with a skepticism bordering hostility.
17 years of semi responsible parenting had severely moderated the Eagle Horn
idea of acceptable life goals.
Really,
they worried that they're chronically unpopular.
Daughters plan to actual living,
shoving food down her throat was a proposition and suicide.
She'd had to declare the discussion ended more than once.
In fact,
she'd never been further from death.
Her regimen was modeled on what she could glean from our idol,
sporadic television appearances and the Internet.
It was surprisingly in step with the recommendations of modern medicine,
eight hours of sleep at night,
daily jobs,
and a strict 1700 calorie diet filled with fruits and vegetables.
Of course,
eating all that food at once is an in many fitness manuals to say nothing of her
biweekly,
all you can eat workouts,
but the overall improvement in Charlie's health was undeniable.
By the fall,
she'd lost 78 pounds and game the beauty and confidence of a girl who truly
believes she has control over food.
Her public enthusiasm of eating competitions did her few favors with her peers,
but her reclaimed featherweight kilter and the offbrand hormones her father
bought online had given her a peculiar prettiness that at least kept boys from
throwing rocks at her.
Her friendship remained a social pitfall.
Lulu alone was willing to risk with 30 seconds left,
something was very wrong and getting worse.
The 83 wings she'd somehow swallowed.
We're now an open revolt.
Terror tied a knot in her stomach,
making her nausea feel all the more urgent she'd eaten beyond her means Charlie
was going to throw up.
Her breath came and shallow gulps.
She wobbled drunkenly as her strength began to break and she closed her eyes.
Clammy,
certainty enveloped her vomiting was intractable and inevitable,
but desperately needed to be stalled.
If a drop of her sick touch the table before the clock ran out,
she'd be disqualified.
A great wave of adrenaline washed up.
The last bit of resolve,
she'd so jealously buried.
It was immediately followed by the half digested ambitions at the back of her
throat.
Charlie's hand shot to her mouth.
A gleeful explosion of pleasure roared out of the voyeuristic crowd.
Her shoulders heaved as though she'd been shoved by an invisible hand and she
teetered slightly forward.
The drool in her mouth tasted like batteries for mass in her guts came flooding
out over her lips and into her waiting palms.
She shuttered violently as she buckled and began to fall.
The final buzzer screamed out over the chaos.
The championship was over.
Charlie's world strobed into blackness and she collapses unconscious into a pile
of puke and victory in her hallucinations.
Charlie watched the big bang spew forth and begin to eat itself.
She perceived a cycle of consumption.
The title glut of energy that crushes stars and digests the cosmos at the center
of each galaxy,
sat an endlessly hungry mouth,
a black hole that bolted down creation and waited for the final Buzzer of
doomsday serenely.
She recognized creation as an elaborate eating contest.
The thought made her happy.
She woke up to the bright white glow of tarp in the sunshine.
Her head lay on a starched sterile pillow and a clear tube of saline dripped
into a vein in the crook of her elbow.
The Bullion Bustle of post-competition commotion outside told Her that she'd
been unconscious for only a few minutes,
though she felt like she'd witnessed Aternity.
Sitting up drew the relieved attention of a kind face young medic on the other
side of the tent.
Her heart fluttered her head throbs and he urged her to lie back down.
She'd almost died.
It was time to rest in a photo finish.
Charlie's vomit had stayed in her hands and off the table until after the
buzzer.
The rules were clear.
Sheet officially finished successfully.
Charlie was a wolf awarded third place,
just five wings shy of the grit sky on the plastic stool next to her cot
paperclip to a $500 check and a handful of Hooters coupons was a business card
with the International Federation of Competitive Eaters logo on it.
She grinned,
grinned,
deliriously belched and fell asleep.
Thank you.
Okay.
It's always awesome to watch the people who kind of lose their shit during that
story.
I've seen him.
That'd be that a lot of times.
It's nice.
Um,
and it was edited many and this is a novel called Nevada that I wrote that just
lost at the lambda literary awards.
It's a story.
It's in two parts.
The first is about a trans woman living in New York City who was a mess,
who was her girlfriend and her job.
And the second part,
um,
she sort of half borrows,
half steals her now ex girlfriend's car and points it west where she winds up at
a Walmart in a small town in Nevada where she sees a kid,
she's in her late twenties.
She sees his kid and she's like,
ah,
you're 19.
And I know you,
you are trans and you don't know it yet.
I'm going to fucking,
I'm going to fix that for you.
Um,
and he's like,
oh,
I don't know about that.
Um,
as a story of nonconsensual mentorship,
um,
and so what I'm going to read,
I'm gonna read apart from the first half of it and then apart from the second
half of it,
when they meet,
um,
or am I,
yeah.
Um,
so the part,
the first part I'm going to read,
she has broken up with her girlfriend.
Her girlfriend broke up with her a little bit ago and she just was fired for her
job because she works at the strand.
Do you know the,
the strand in New York City tricks it to bookstore?
She tends to kind of just leave and walk around lower Manhattan on the clock.
Um,
so she's just been fired for that.
And that's that.
You could be melodramatic and say,
just like that.
Maria Griffiths is homeless and unemployed in New York City.
The reality though is that she has had,
or she has a bunch of places to crash,
so it would be appropriative to call herself homeless.
Okay.
She says,
great.
I'm just going to grab my stuff from the back and then I'll be on my wife.
She is in the process of being fired.
Okay.
She says,
great.
I'm just going to grab my stuff from the back and I'll be on my way.
I'll cheerful.
Someone will bring you your things.
Mcneely says,
mcneilly's an angry,
obviously supervisor who is in the process of firing her.
Mcneely says,
you're really not going to let me go back to the closet to get my bag.
You don't work here anymore.
He says,
looking off to one side,
already bored with this conversation.
Some new kid brings her bag up.
They must've watched her leave and prepared for this awkward,
but whatever.
Once again,
her response surprises her.
She's kind of excited.
She laughs in the old fuckers face,
takes her bag and walks back into the rain.
She practically knocks over the terrifying owner of the store who has just
arrived in a cab or a car service or whatever.
Right.
On time for work.
I'm not going to read this section for Youtube.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's a lot of stuff I don't read on Youtube.
Um,
Maria starts immediately to regret that she didn't get a jab in,
but whatever.
She's outside in the rain and she's got the whole afternoon to herself the whole
week.
Actually it hits her again that she's pretty excited not to have a job anymore,
even though that means no more money until she can find another one and no more
health insurance.
Who Cares?
She never has to go back to that job.
She was so indifferent about for so long because she absolutely completely hates
her life in New York.
Whoa.
Sometimes your internal monologue surprises you.
She thinks about going back to the apartment.
She is probably still stay still sharing with Steph,
but seeing all steps,
things would probably be kind of rough right now.
Then she thinks about going to hang out with Parana.
Uh,
her best friend,
his name Purana.
She thinks about going to hang out with Parana,
but she is probably going to be asking Khurana if she can crash at her house a
lot pretty soon.
So she had better not just start taking up space.
They're immediately,
she could go see a movie,
but suddenly being broke is a lot more real than it was a couple of hours ago
and $10 for a two hour distractions seems irresponsible,
like bad,
irresponsible.
She decided to go to [inaudible] dot.
Coffee.
It is this biggest coffee shop on avenue a where they have computers and stuff,
but also couches and expensive coffee and atmosphere.
It's cooler than the coffee shop by the bookstore,
like in a gentrification sense.
Uh,
as the last APP act of epic,
brutal punk rock defiance,
she steps two feet back into the door of the bookstore and grabs an umbrella out
of the umbrella basket.
Ha.
She leaves her bike chained up outside the bookstore,
under the awning where they'll stay dry and walks the six long blocks to ave a,
it's so gray out it rules.
This has been her favorite kind of weather since she was a little kid.
She loves going after being in the rain when you're kind of wet and cold,
but you immediately start warming up and you finally start to feel just how wet
you are.
As soon as you start to dry out and then you can look outside and see the rain,
wash it,
run down the windows,
and nobody can realistically ask you to go outside and play.
New Yorkers walk by and ignore her cubs splash puddle water everywhere.
Nobody waits for the don't walk.
Sign to turn to walk before they crossed the street.
Rain looks like it's freezing to the frail branches of the city.
Trees.
Maybe the rain will start to freeze.
Turn the sidewalks.
IC It's fall,
so it might happen,
but it's very early fall so it might not.
This umbrella is enormous and it's got a Nike logo on it.
Punk rock.
Indeed,
that man that she has been calling herself Batman in her internal monologue.
It's pretty wise.
Punk Rock,
indeed Batman,
she says to herself as she retracts the umbrella and it goes into the hip.
Coffee Shop.
They have an umbrella bucket and she worries for a second about whether someone
will steal her umbrella.
Then laughs at herself.
Who Cares?
It probably do some good for somebody to steal her stolen umbrella so she would
have to walk back to her bike in the rain.
She thinks about how good a hot shower fields when you're soaked in cold rain.
Here's the thing,
she's been thinking a lot about knuckle tattoos and half.
You have eight letters.
You can make a knuckle tattoo.
The next line is umbrella,
she thinks but it is spelled out in blocks of four letters so as to appear and
the shape of knuckle tattoos.
She's thinking about having the word umbrella tattooed on her knuckles.
She didn't bring a book and she doesn't really know what she's going to do at
the coffee shop.
Spend money on Internet access to look at help wanted ads on craigslist.
Her resume from years ago is probably somewhere in her email.
She can update it to include this most recent job.
Act like she left without being fired.
Lie and say a friend is a manager who thinks she was a great employee.
She can use her real name,
not her legal one and just not freak out about it.
If anybody asks,
just tell them she's transit the interview.
If she gets an interview,
that way it'll be out in the open,
at least with the management at her new job,
which will be as somebody who's assistant at a publishing company or something,
she gets a $3 drip coffee and gives the borrower star her license.
She doesn't look at it,
but she's got daycare so she probably wouldn't care if she saw the M.
Maria is assigned computer number 23 but after 15 minutes of looking at
craigslist,
her eyes glaze over and she's falling asleep sitting up.
She doesn't have the energy to email that girl.
She does not feel like job searching.
She's like,
do I even want to stay in New York?
She doesn't actually have to.
She goes back up to it to the counter,
tells the girl that she has done on the computer and gets her license back $5
for 15 minutes.
She takes her coffee over to a couch,
sits down and takes out her notebook.
October 15th part three I hate New York,
but I love The New York rain and autumn,
like the November rain,
but it is October and I just got fired from the stupid bookstore.
I didn't even cuss out anybody.
Now I have to figure out what the fuck to do with myself.
Do I get a new job in Brooklyn near my apartment except I'm going to have to
find another apartment too.
I am exhausted from thinking about being trans all the time and I wish I could
stop.
If you work for the city of San Francisco,
dear diary,
did you know that they will pay for bottom surgery for you?
It might be an urban legend.
Maybe.
I will look into it.
It didn't even occur to me to go out and get drunk after I got fired,
which is interesting.
It's almost like I got drunk all the time when I was dating stuff and working a
shitty job.
Not because I am a total addict,
but because it was a coping mechanism to deal with being unhappy.
Her hand hurts already.
It sucks that being from the computer generation means she cannot write longhand
like at all.
She texted her,
Ana,
can I stay with you again tonight?
Get fired a little.
She puts the phone back in her car.
She puts the phone back in their pocket,
but it rings immediately.
It's Perona.
She stands up and goes outside because who cares what everybody else does?
Who cares that they're only three other people in the coffee shop at 2:00 PM on
a Wednesday.
It is rude to talk on your phone when other people are trying to concentrate.
Dude,
Parana says hi.
Maria says maybe more cheerful than she actually is.
I'm working tonight,
but you can come get the key for me at work and stay at my house while I'm out
and like take a shower or whatever.
Thanks.
Maria says,
but listen,
you can't just stay at my house all the time,
you know?
Yeah,
I was parented.
Cuts her off.
I know,
you know,
but it's like,
dude,
Maria,
besides the occasional text I hear from you once every two or three months
because you're so occupied with your girlfriend all the time and now suddenly
you want to hang out all day every day because you don't have to worry about her
anymore.
It feels Kinda fucked to me.
Shit.
Yeah,
I know.
Listen,
Parana says I'm not going to put you out on the street,
especially if you just got fired from work and I want,
I want you to tell me all about that.
I'm not super pissed at you or anything.
I just need you to understand that I feel kind of resentful about the fact that
you have ignored me pretty bad for so long and now that you've got a reason
besides that you're excited to hang out with me.
Suddenly we are besties or whatever.
Okay.
Maria says probably hurt the most deeply that she's been in these last couple of
days.
I miss you.
Parana says,
and I'm excited to see you again,
but I needed to put that out there.
I've got to go to work at nine.
Come see me then.
Okay.
Yeah.
Maria says,
okay,
the hang up now,
her mood has come back to earth and she feels like shit.
Maybe she should get a beer.
It turns out they have two for one beers after four at high fi half a block
away,
but Maria doesn't wait until four.
Then when four o'clock hits she has her third and Fourth Beers and falls asleep
on the bar for a couple hours.
Who knows why the skinny pretty bartender lets her sleep.
That's kind of off limits in most bars.
Maybe having a transsexual pass out at your bar for a couple hours is the kind
of gritty authenticity that a bar on the lower east side needs.
Now that everybody has moved to Brooklyn,
that's the first part I'm going to read.
Uh,
this next is section is from the perspective of James Who's 19.
He was smoking a lot of weed so he doesn't have to think about gender or have
any feelings about gender.
Um,
he smokes out before he gets to work,
but by hour four or so of a nine hour shift,
he is not really feeling stoned anymore.
Every day.
By this point,
he mostly feels tired and pissed off.
He's always wished he could be the kind of cool Badass who smokes out at work,
but there is no way you could do it with some without somebody finding out,
plus his mom rides in his car.
Sometimes you can't even hotbox it ever.
It's actually very possible that this is why he hates his job so much.
He's like,
I should think about that.
Every single day I go through an unstowed dinning and fucking hate my life and
my job in my house and my girlfriend and everyone and everything that I can see.
It seems like that probably affects my job satisfaction.
I end each shift with a headache.
I need a fix because I am addicted to the sheet demon marijuana.
It is getting toward the end of the shift and James isn't stone anymore and it's
sucks.
This old guy who comes in once or twice a week was looking for some stupid old
movies that he couldn't find because Walmart does not carry stupid old movies,
but this guy doesn't listen to James at all,
so they always wind up spending half an hour pretending to look for these DVDs
that are not there.
That's probably a metaphor for life and star city actually,
whatever once or twice a week.
James,
thanks very seriously about writing out a note to have a waiting for this guy
the next time he comes in that explains that these are very,
very old and Hokey movies starring actors that nobody cares about anymore and
that he would be better off going to the family dollar over an inlay where they
saw those mass produce DVDs of public domain stuff that feel all light in your
hands,
like there's no DVD in them.
Walmart can't even order them.
Those DVD companies have their own distributors that Walmart doesn't use,
which is weird since it seems like the distributors that make those wholesome
DVDs would be Christian and Walmart doesn't shy away from Christian anything but
whatever.
Who Cares?
James has a headache.
He needs to smoke out again in this old guy is starting to seem done with
playing out this scenario yet again.
When Maria Griffiths come strutting up the aisle of the Walmart looking out of
place as hell like she is made out of long red hair and layers of clothing.
James does what anybody would do and they see somebody they would like to know.
He ignores the shit out of her probably he freaks out a little,
but she came right to the music and movies section,
so what else could he do?
He says hi to her when she first comes in because he can get in trouble if he
doesn't.
According to Walmart,
corporate policy greetings,
turn thieves into friends,
but then he just ignores her is how maybe on some level he notices that she
might've looked for or looked at him for a second longer than was appropriate,
but if you have things,
anything,
it's like suck it up dude.
That girl is definitely not checking you out.
She's wearing more clothes than he has ever seen anyone wear it once.
Huge black boots,
a long black skirt,
or maybe address what looks like a shorter dark orange skirt on top of it.
Along maroonish sweater under a ratty denim jacket with a bunch of patches and
buttons on it.
A black scarf and wavy dried out looking hair just past her shoulders.
Her hair is almost exactly the same color as her sweater,
but a little bit darker.
They probably clash or whatever her clothes look like.
She slept in them.
They're permanent looking crinkles in the elbows of her jacket and her hair
looks like it would leave a mark if she leaned her head against a wall.
She looks like she's probably a rock star or a murderer.
One time the band,
one time the band creed came to is Walmart on tour to buy batteries or something
and everybody flipped out even though creed is a stupid band,
but James saw one of the guys from the band and he walked with this magnetism or
swagger or something like he knew he was a big deal and Maria carries herself
kind of the same way.
She walks over to the pop slash rock CD display and James thinks clearly,
who the fuck wears a scarf in the daytime and star city,
especially during a heat wave.
While he's ignoring her,
he stares at her back.
This is good.
I bet Google people will get those ready.
Who the fuck?
Uh,
where's the scarf and the daytime and star city,
especially during a heat wave.
While he is ignoring hair.
He stares at her back.
Steven Tyler,
the fourth doctor.
Yeah.
Great.
There's always like one or two people who were like,
did you didn't just cool the fourth doc.
It's a doctor who illusion James Watches a lot of TV.
He is seriously just being a creep and staring at her because people who look
like that do not live here.
They don't stop here while they're driving through either.
There are other Walmarts closer to the highway,
like three exits away in either direction.
It was fucking dumb for Walmart to put a Walmart here.
Well,
nobody comes here except for creed.
Once she flips through the pop slash rock cds for a second and James Manages to
look away from the poison patch safety pin across her back and the Msci wavy
hair sprawling.
It's weighed down at like poison,
the Glam rock band with a singer who does reality TV shows.
Now his headache fades or else James just forgets about it because when she
turns around,
he's very intently alphabetizing cds that have just come in and need to be
shelved.
Hey,
she says,
looking him up and down again.
James is like,
hi,
do you have the Miranda Lambert album?
Um,
he says,
probably,
but it's probably in the country's section.
She's like,
oh,
there's a country section.
And he's like,
well,
yeah then because he was feeling totally weird.
James doesn't even stop himself.
He just blurts out,
you don't look like the folks who usually shop there though.
Because if he is being totally honest with himself on some level,
James has already figured out that this girl is trans and while he hasn't
processed what that means yet,
he is having this desperate magnetic attraction to her.
Like not even sexual,
just like,
I want to be your Facebook friend.
I need to grab you to have you in my life.
Whatever.
You don't look like the folks who usually shop here.
That is a pretty dumb thing to say,
but she doesn't disagree.
She looks at his name tag,
smirks and says,
that's probably true James H,
but check this out.
I left New York City about a week ago and my dog,
my cat and I had been living out of my car since then driving out to the west
coast solely because we have never seen it in New York City.
They're Spanish music stations,
wrap stations,
dumb rock stations and little stations run by painfully self-aware college
students with no idea what to do with all their privilege besides collect
records and gentrify neighborhoods that have been fine for generations,
but I don't think there's a country station in New York.
I guess there are a lot of reggaeton stations,
which in a lot of ways people tend to not even notice has a lot of similarities
to country music.
By the way.
People have asked me,
Oh yeah,
how's Vegas tone?
Similar to country.
It's not,
this is Maria being an idiot.
Anyway.
It turns out though that once you leave New York,
which nobody should ever do,
j k the only things you can,
the only thing that you can consistently get on a 12 year old car stereo or NPR
and country stations and have you ever listened to NPR?
It's soothing for awhile,
but eventually it makes you want to call in and cuss somebody out until you cry.
It wouldn't get onto the radio because I guess they have enough lag time to dump
out angry people who call up and lose their shit.
But it turned me off NPR for a while,
which means country station after country station for the last four days.
And look,
I am not some New York jerk who thinks country music is for Yoko's or something.
I'm into it.
I get it.
I even think it's kind of nice that country singers are so fucking convinced of
their own sincerity that they don't do any of the tortured artist.
I don't care if you'd like me.
It's art man posturing that all the Indie rock kids do and they don't spend all
day telling me about how tough and rich they are.
Like the rappers on the radio do except James Age.
There's also a lot of dumb shit on country radio.
I'm so much cooler online.
She thinks my tractor's sexy.
I guess it's funny the first time but,
but Maria has followed James over to the country music section and is jabbing
her pointer finger toward his chest.
I guess she says Miranda Lambert isn't the biggest star in the country sky
because I've only heard the radio play her a couple of times but I think all her
songs are about like burning down,
cheating ex boyfriends houses and like shooting your abusive ex in the face.
The first time I heard that song I was like finally someone is just coming out
and threading,
threatening to kill her asshole boyfriend right there on the radio.
Not that I think anybody should kill anybody else or anything,
but after five days of country radio,
consider me brainwashed,
Miranda Lambert.
James H is the punk shit on the radio and I'm going to drive my car off a cliff.
If I hear the song about how the guy hopes he gets a chance to live like he was
dying ever again,
not because I don't like it because it is so sad and true that it makes me want
to live like I was dying and then die.
So James H.
Miranda Lambert is a contingency plan to save my life.
She actually said the Internet abbreviation for just kidding.
Out Loud.
There's a pause and then she smirked and she's like,
sorry,
I haven't really talked to anybody in awhile.
James is like,
it's cool.
He picks up Mirandas and then Miranda Lambert second album and hands it to her.
This is the CD with that song about the gunpowder and led on it.
He says,
thank you James H.
She says,
you've been very helpful.
Then she starts to leave the movies and cds department.
Wait,
James says you've got to buy it here.
I'll security will kick my ass.
This is kind of true.
Mostly true.
You're supposed to get people to buy their music and DVDs and the music and DVDs
section.
Even though there isn't like a rule about it.
It's a firm's suggestion in the interest of loss prevention,
but it is a stupid thing to emphasize just then.
It's not like he's going to slip or his phone number on the receipt.
Well,
the receipt does have the phone number for Walmart number eight three zero four
on it.
If she wants to call him,
I don't think they can take you.
She says you look like a total bruiser.
Yeah,
he says totally.
I'm a regular old Brad Paisley.
We were just talking about Brad Paisley in the car before him.
Brad Paisley is great.
I'm a regular old Brad Paisley,
which one is Brad Paisley.
You know,
he says,
I don't highlight my hair and I've still got a pair.
Rias eyes lit up and she quotes from this dumb country song,
my eyebrows plucked and there's a gun in my truck.
That's me.
He says,
honey,
I'm still a guy.
It's $10 and 90 cents the weirdness of that exchange is not lost on either of
them.
Maria pays with a debit card.
James notices that her pin is six six six four then she leaves and he thinks,
well fuck.
Then his headache is back and he gets pretty bummed so he starts thinking about
how like soon he's going to go home and get high as fuck.
Smoking weed rules and the fact that this girl just showed up in his life and
now she has gone forever.
Totally sucks.
He's thinking about this weird girl who was just here whose name he doesn't even
know because she paid with a pen instead of credit and then his thoughts
naturally and turned to his Goto nonsexual fantasy weed.
He isn't.
He's envisioning like laying down in the sprawling fields of the marijuana farms
of Northern California but she keeps stumping in even though it is goto fantasy
even though it is his goto fantasy,
James is aware that it is pretty boring.
More interesting things tend to intrude like fantasizing about laying down in a
field of wheat crops.
It's like licking the centerfold of an issue of high times.
He just keeps thinking like New York City,
her and a dog and a cat in a car for a week.
What the fuck is Reggaeton Trans?
It's weird that he could tell that she was trans.
You could tell but not and like an obvious way.
Like if a drag queen came,
parading up the aisle,
you couldn't really tell from the way she looked or the way she talked or
anything probably.
But then you have to ask yourself like,
well how could I tell?
It was probably some combination of things,
but could other people tell it?
Was he going to have that or was he going to have to have stupid conversations
for the next three months with idiot coworkers about the freaky queer that was
in the store that one time.
Gross.
Weird.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
hi everyone.
I'm Casey Plat and the last one,
and I'm going to read a story out of this book that I just wrote called the safe
girl to love,
which is a collection of short stories are all about young trans women.
And I'm going to read a story that part of the story,
couple of excerpts that I haven't read yet.
Um,
uh,
what's a story called winning and it is set in Eugene,
Oregon,
um,
out in the northwest and it is about a girl and her mom.
It's going to start at the beginning.
So
he's shivering.
Zoe thought as she came in Robin's bedroom and saw his tall Muslim pudge body
vibrating on the bed,
blanket on the floor.
She made to Tuck the blanket back over him.
When she saw his face was contorted and his lips were moving like waves.
She said,
hey,
and softly rocky shoulder Robin gasps and his face turned it instantly blind.
Hey,
I'm sorry to wake you.
It's okay.
He said he stretched in his boxers,
made a roughly noise in the sheets you leaving?
He said,
yeah.
She said,
thanks for letting me crash.
Definitely.
Boy,
he on,
I feel fucked up.
Robin finished most of make them last night.
Zoe had two glasses and switch to milk.
She loves milk.
She giggled and said,
aw,
and must is wavy brown hair.
It was silly.
She realized walking outside and zipping her hoodie up over her dress,
but she had forgotten that boys even had nightmares at all.
It was mid November when in the Pacific northwest,
the Panorama of clouds stop flirting with the sky and moved in and set their
parking brakes until Mary,
a soft Ms Patter of rain was coming down.
A Zooey walked down the motel like stairs,
a province complex.
Then over to Eugene station,
take the 66 bucks north.
She got on and texted her best friend,
Giulia back in New York.
Hi.
She said you're beautiful and I miss you to fucking pieces.
When she got off the bus and walk up to Iris Road,
the rain had stopped,
but the sky was still an pearl gray.
Zoe hated this humans,
I'm supposed to go months with all their sunlight broken.
She thought she had actually loved the winters in New York.
Everyone they're complaining about gray,
but to Zoe,
New York had been sunny and bright back at her mom's.
The boxes in the kitchen hadn't moved.
There was a note on the counter which said,
I've gone to the farmer's market when last time I need everything out of your
room tonight.
Well,
that was in New York class.
She still had a week to stay here,
but whatever.
She went into her room and resume clearing out her shit.
You can build up so much stuff.
When you have a room in a house you don't actually live in.
She thought and so he'd always been a pack rat.
Even as a teenager she would save a lot of the things that you thought.
Regular families safe for their kids,
but you don't know so that stuff now though,
and there are only a few boxes left,
orderly C's of social studies,
papers,
choir programs and stuff like that.
Sandy came home as though he was smashing a basketball sized paper Wad into the
recycling.
I bought some fruit for you.
Her mother said,
I'm not hungry.
Said Zoe,
don't give me that.
Have you eaten?
I don't want any fruit.
Thanks Sandy.
Wash bag of Bartlett pears and plunked it tripping on the counter.
She put her elbows beside the big and massage your eyes better to tell me the
truth.
Don't you think?
Ever since,
so he transitioned.
Sandy had become convinced that her daughter would develop an eating disorder.
Those Zoe was eating as little as ever,
you know.
Thanks mom.
So he said,
I'm not hungry.
Zoe is,
Sandy said,
the last thing I want to do is have to make you eat.
It's not like I like having this conversation.
Sandy was trans too,
so we could come up to her exactly 18 months ago on the phone from her Brooklyn
apartment after she'd already been on hormones for awhile.
She meticulously,
she'd meticulously taken steps to avoid telling her and when she had,
her mother had cried and cried and cried her phone pulsed.
And so each site and other texts from Juliette,
you're beautiful,
I miss you.
And so he picked up the biggest pair and took a Gargantuan bite.
What do you need help with next?
She asked,
Sandy had done a lot to have Zoe with Sandy,
his wife at the time.
Taher.
This was back in the mid Eighties Sandy,
the center for chest certificates to the clinic where she banged her sperm,
who then sent the samples to a friend of Tay is a nurse practitioner who then
helped within seven eight and this is on the planes for Sandy.
And Tay had grown up.
They moved to Oregon to have Zoe who was born downtown in an apartment off
eighth avenue.
So He loved this story as he never got tired of telling us her friends back
east.
She liked to say that she had been born loved though Taylor left both of them
when Zooey was eight and sandy had not always been the most stable if mothers.
So he had always felt acres of love.
Can you go through the closet in the spare room?
Sandy said,
no problem.
Said so,
hey,
have another pair if you want it.
They're completely yours.
Sandy called after her so he didn't respond.
So she got out pita bread and Hummus and went to her desk in the living room to
do paperwork.
She passed.
Well,
her mother did and so he had always admired for her that.
And now that she herself a transition,
she especially admired it.
Now,
in the old days,
no one had known about sandy and with her being six one and broad shouldered and
poor is that he thought it really couldn't have been easy.
I always wore jeans.
Sandy told Zoe wants when Zoe's 17 it had been the fifth anniversary of Sandy's
bottom surgery and she'd been unusually talkative about the subject.
I always wear jeans.
She said almost never skirts or dresses because Justin People's heads
subconsciously,
the idea of trainees wearing jeans doesn't Mesh.
Zoe had listened to this rapidly.
They said,
I looked manage San Diego,
but they never thought I was a man.
I tricked him and she sounded like she was floating.
She said,
you know,
they just passed me off as some big earthy dyke.
Well,
you know,
that's okay.
From very early in her childhood.
So he knew that sandy had one slid as a man.
Neither of her mother's had hidden it from her,
but it was also understood to be a buried subject,
something gravely serious,
as though he was never supposed to talk or ask about.
I did have some really pretty dresses.
Sandy had said in the conversation,
but I had to be very careful about wearing them.
I just had to be careful.
They moved out to the apartment off eighth when Zoe was in third grade.
It had been right after Taylor left and right when sandy got her job with the
county.
That's when they got one of the few bungalows left along Ayers on the north edge
of town,
just shy of the city line.
Sandy was from the country and she missed the stars.
She said she missed the stars and the quiet.
Okay.
Skipping to another section more middle eighth today.
This the story.
Okay,
so now he's that way.
He's just gotten a job at a call center doing surveys and this is her first day
at work.
On the third call she stuttered a bit because the man on the phone,
certainly dairy farmer outside Pacific city sounded exactly like a man she'd
known back in New York,
a guy with layered blonde hair who ran a bar in Williamsburg wallpapered with
covers of Gattis books.
They had gone out for dinner,
then out dancing.
The man had been amazingly charming gentleman me.
She accepted all of the drinks.
He bought her and back at his place,
he began squeezing her nipples and stuffing his hands south.
And her last memory was as much really shaking her head,
wait,
hold on.
I like you.
I want to.
It's like,
wait.
And when she woke up,
she was on his bed alone and he was at his desk on his computer,
and those sides of her bottom had a dull vomit spring lake.
How many milk giving cows did you say?
Said Zoe.
Now,
I'm sorry.
Including heifers that are not yet.
52 said the man.
Now,
do you have at this time or do I need to repeat it again?
You tell me here.
And so he said,
yes,
of course.
Of course,
sir.
And by nine o'clock so he had covered this scratch paper on her office desk with
black and white penciled swirls and shapes,
criss crossing paisleys and hectic grandson.
Triple Helix is on the outlines of faces.
Some of the faces resembled her mom,
her mom.
So we had always seen her mother is deadly gorgeous.
She had short coiffed ash blonde hair like Sharon Stone and casino without the
rat tail.
She wear blue or green skinny jeans,
tank tops,
which shiny satin edge.
I said edges that showed up lightly muscled swimmers arms and long earrings
that's scattered around her colorbond wherever she moved her head in winter,
she worked cable and separate hoodies and Zoe on the other hand kept her hair
black like dresses with stripes or Polka dots.
See through glasses ever camisoles the patterns sweater,
tights in winter she spent through tubes that eyeliner and Lipstick Sandy,
maybe you still a little mascara once in a while.
Even as though he took no part of her own style from her if she had to be
honest.
So dressed a bit like our other Meyer,
other mother Tonya who now spoiled here with clothes on visits.
Zoe did admire the wave.
Sandy looked,
she admired a lot about her mother really.
She admired the way she hadn't hid from Zooey the pain of Taya leaving her,
but she rarely bad most or castigated Taya herself and given the ta had to party
with the load of their money.
And a note including the words like anyone else would have loved you.
She would have had plenty of reason.
She admired how sandy treated Zoe's boyfriends in high school.
The one she'd drag up from south of the UFO cause no gay boys were out of her
own school and how sandy you welcomed them and cook for them even when sometimes
they were snotty to her.
She admired the sex talk sandy had given her when she was really young,
before puberty,
sandy had told her,
now this is a thing that teenagers and adults like to do and they get to do.
Kids don't,
it's not a kid thing.
You don't even want to do it and you shouldn't,
but this will happen.
What will happen when you're older and it can be wonderful,
but it is important.
You're safe.
There's a safe way to do it in an unsafe way and it's like driving without a
seatbelt where something bad happens,
you can die,
but if you're safe,
it gives you freedom.
You can't imagine the happiness and the freedom when you're older.
I will help you and we can talk about it.
This is something that I want you to do,
right?
And it's something that I want you to look forward to.
I want us to be a good and healthy part of your life.
She had said,
and so we really admired that,
especially when she found out about all of Sandy's friends who died or in what
she'd only for referred to as the plague.
So he had remembered a few of them from when she was a kid,
but only faintly and only a few.
Thanks for your time sir.
So he said to her last call.
Yeah.
Good night man.
The man grumbled Zooey folded the drawing.
She made thought of sticking them in her bag and then drop them in the trash.
Not the recycling,
the trash.
So New York,
Huh?
The supervisor asked as they left their building together after the work.
After work.
Sorry,
why'd you come here?
Zoe was really tired of answering that question and lately she's just been
snapping.
I'm helping my mom in a tone that made everyone think her mom had a deadly
illness and needed,
so either tend to her last days or something.
It usually got people to leave her alone.
But when she said that now who supervised Subaru?
Ooh,
Ooh.
Too much coffee.
But when she said that now her supervisor just said,
Huh,
do you like it here though?
Like do you think you want to stay here in Eugene?
So he considered how to answer that to a stranger.
Well,
I grew up here.
She said softly walking down darkened slick Willamette street with their hoodie
up in the sprinkle Mr Rein.
It occurred to her that she'd walked these streets late often since coming back,
but hadn't been propositioned to harassed once and Eugene or be made to feel
that safe in any way.
Really.
When Zooey was a kid,
she thought she looked in a great town.
She thought no place was better than this little city.
A Term Taya had liked to use.
Oh,
this little city is though he didn't like the neighborhood.
They'd ended up in a weird little bumpkin and religious yuppy enclave,
but she loved downtown and she left the Ufo and she even loved the dumb
political battles that played out in the city bike paths to the Catholic school.
The cross Skinner's dispute where to build a new hospital.
All the little clashes between right and left hippies and Mormon Mormon's
developers and virus.
It had felt like that's stupid idea of what America was supposed to be and no
one was from there.
It was a place that you moved to even from middle school on and it seemed like
being born in town,
put her in the minority and when she was a teenager leaving just didn't occur to
her like,
why would you do that if you are lucky enough to be from here?
She thought when she left home,
she just get a room in a house back downtown by the Weill Hall and go be a
stupid duck for four years,
then get a job and a little house of her own.
Then there should be there she be,
as her mom would say,
in one of her few kept Midwestern isms and so he was rarely bitter about being
trans.
If you needed to believe in the possibility of unmetered Trans Women,
Zoe would be your girl,
but she knew she wouldn't have left.
If it hadn't been for that,
she would've stayed.
She would have gone to the country fair,
signed on with the Co op,
checked in on her mom live the beautiful new liberal American life.
It had been so close hell on the face of it.
The town that's current era had been designed specifically for someone like her,
like who else,
if not for the fag,
Kate of a woman like sandy queer and transplanted and the hippy to boot.
So we had really always thought it was a great town.
She'd never hated that growing up,
ever,
ever.
But she knew that staying meant a boy.
Future,
a pretend to be CIS future.
She didn't have the strength to figure out the gender thing you're on.
Everyone she'd known and she known that in part from her mom.
You couldn't transition and keep everything else in your life the same.
It couldn't happen.
She tested it.
If it one summer by telling a few friends about sandy the one she thought in
react the best and the looks on their faces,
especially her boyfriends of revulsion of horror,
the things they said about her mother.
One just said simple,
dumb stuff like,
Oh groceries,
your dad,
that is fuck up.
That is fucked up.
And another said,
Huh,
well she was too pretty to actually be real anyway.
Hey,
maybe he'll be a penguin next huh.
Though the worst was a girl,
a close friend who looked ashen and said,
you know,
it sucks.
I knew she had problems,
but I still looked up to her as a strong woman.
I thought I had this strong woman in my life.
I thought you had this strong mother.
So he climbed out about telling clammed up about telling anyone after that she
didn't even mention it to Frankie and old best friend of hers.
And so when fall came and she applied for and speaking to a fancy school in the
east coast,
she saw for the first time in her town and void and less black,
she'll be forever grateful.
She grew up there.
But the future we saw it was,
she saw it was for some willowy gay kid.
Lovely but not her.
And everyone's fucking attitudes about trans stuff changes so quickly.
After a few years,
Chaz Thomas Beatie,
all those fucks.
Had she been born five years later,
she thought some time that she might've felt like she could have stayed.
So Zoe was bitter about that.
She looked away from her supervisor and adjusted her bag.
I don't mind it.
She said quietly,
there's a lot of worse places to be.
Oh Jesus said the supervisor,
you have no idea.
I love it here.
And he started talking about his hometown in Arizona and how there were grocery
stores and bars here in Eugene.
He just loved and you'd never find that where he was from.
And it's even the people were so nice,
like they gave a shit about being humans here.
You know,
he had great eyes and the kind of sparkle as he talk.
So he said,
uh Huh.
Totally.
And decided to picture this guy.
Al Lube didn't naked until it got to the bus station where she returned some
techs and her supervisor got on the 24 going somewhere south.
Thank you.
[inaudible].